you are watching cold-case Channel hey  guys welcome to another video this one's  kind of by a popular request a lot of  people have been sending me messages and  kind of asking me to put together  another wallpaper back and in HD this  time so you know I went along and did  that so this is kind of an art  technology so bringing art and  technology together in an interesting  way the selected wallpapers really just  pieces that caught my design I anyway  I'll show them to you now and I'll catch  up with you after this  so yeah that's most of them if you want  it come and get it the continuum  wallpaper pack along with previous  wallpaper packs will be inside the  description anyway hopefully there's a  few wallpapers in there that you like  and don't forget to rate comment and  subscribe I'll see you again soon for  the next video thank you